all right brad yes brad where'd you grow
up where are you from i'm from
burnsville north carolina very small
town
tell me about your family you had mom
and dad um i never met my dad
i grew up with my mom and my grandma
my grandma owned a business so i kind of
had the two extremes my mom was paranoid
schizophrenic pretty severe
and um
like she was very very abusive towards
me pretty brutal but my grandma gave me
everything i wanted
but my grandma didn't help me because
she didn't want to have a bad face in
the community so it was
it was kind of tough and
then um
eventually my mom the disease got the
better of her with drug addiction and um
she killed herself when i was 16
committed suicide
wow how she did that
um
well the night it happened
um i was going to movies with my friends
and as all went she was on a real rant
that night she used to run around the
house thinking there were bats above her
head she was
gone and um it got worse and worse you
grew up with us oh yeah oh yeah she
would um ask me to come sit on her lap
she'd throw me across the room
call me the f word i don't want to use
it but that's that's a trigger for me it
always has been
but um
tell me i was worth nothing just
but anyway that night um i was going to
movies with friends as i walked out of
the house i saw her slam my grandma
against the wall she'd never put her
hands on my grandma and i loved my
grandma
and um
i ran back in the house i was like back
off you know i was like leave her alone
she's precious to me you know what i'm
saying
and um so i went on the movies my mom
showed up at the movie theater tripping
accusing me of smoking pot i was an
honor student i didn't touch drugs right
i was against all that she's the one
that use drugs she's like you need to
come home now i'm like i'm 16 i'll stay
if i want to you know i'm like you're
out of your mind please go home you're
embarrassing me which she was
eventually she left i stayed there about
15 more minutes i'm like i feel like i
should get home
and i went home and um i came in and she
was sitting there still raging at my
grandma i was like back off you know and
i made her sit down i was like look
she had just got out of the hospital two
weeks before that for her schizophrenia
i was like look i said we've done
everything the hospital asked us to do
for you
and you've gotten no better and i looked
her in the face and i said we can't love
you better that's what i told her and i
said and i'm sick of it and i'll spit on
your grave i'm done with you i just
couldn't take it anymore i snapped i'd
never done that before
and i went up to my room and i got on
the phone with a little girlfriend i had
and then we were talking and i came down
to get a snack and my mom was sitting
there crying on the couch just crying
and i was like look i said you're doing
what you deserve you need to learn
to treat me and her with respect because
we're trying our best for you you know i
was like you need to learn sit there and
try and think about it i talked to her
like a child sort of at that point and i
went back up to my room
and um
i need i didn't hear anything
i'd heard her sobbing i didn't hear
anything and i kind of went down the
steps i guess i was going to check on
her i don't really know what i was going
to do and as i got to the bottom i
looked to the right and her pal
like that and she stood up and she spun
around and she fell on the floor
right i was like what the hell
and um i said i gotta go my mom shot
herself i remember saying that to my
little girlfriend and i threw the phone
down and i ran over there and i looked
at her i was like you're faking like
that and um it's not like the movies
mark
half of her face was like seasoned and
gone and half of her face was normal it
was the freakiest thing ever she showed
herself where in the chest right here
she had what's called a stuck in chest
wound it was bad she did it she made
sure she did it right with a 410 gauge
shotgun
so she leaned in forward and put the gun
on the floor and used her thumb
to pop the trigger and it shot the gun
up and the gun busted the window behind
her it had that much force and the whole
house filled with smoke
i mean it puts off way more it wasn't
that loud though it sounded just like a
door slamming pretty much i guess where
she had it up against her skin you know
it muffled it a little i don't know but
um
i ran over there and i i guess i was in
shock i thought she was faking because
she had done that before she had
pretended to kill herself to freak with
to [ __ ] with me to mess with my head
and
that kills a kid you know well i stood
there i'm like you're faking again and
then i saw the blood coming out from
underneath her where she'd shot herself
it was just spreading that is like the
movies it was just spreading and i said
oh my god and i grabbed the phone and i
called 9-1-1 my grandma was froze just
standing there looking
oh my god oh my god is pretty much what
she was saying last thing my mom said
was no everybody remember that when
you're about to kill yourself my mom
said mama no was the last two things she
said
anyway
um i called 9-1-1 the first cop got
there in a minute and a half we lived
right in the little town and um he ran
in and he's like get saran wrap and i
and i heard him get on the radio and
he's like i got a sucking chest wound
he's like man this is bad and i went and
got saran wrap and he put it on there
and it went boom and it shot into her
chest i was like holy i saw all this
there was a hole in her chest
and um
i went in the kitchen i remember this
part and it was just me and my grandma
and the cop there still and i didn't
think i could do anymore
or i don't know what possessed me to do
this but i walked in the kitchen and i
just dropped the phone and i fell down
on my knees
and i was like oh my god do you know
and i just sat there like that for
i don't know until my great uncle came
in there because i don't have anybody
but my grandma my mom i had an aunt but
she's i have no she has nothing to do
with me i guess because i've used drugs
she has nothing to do with me where was
your dad huh where was your dad never
met him never met him
and drugs have never been an issue for
you yeah or they have oh yeah i'm on
suboxone i'm in recovery 16 months so
you started using after this oh yes oh
okay oh yeah i fell down slippery slow
quick
marijuana
i still use marijuana but that's all now
um
i got see after she died
well anyway oh i'll tell you this um my
uncle got me up he's like brad it's just
a flesh wound
i was like i know better man
he's like it'll be all right she'll be
i'll it'll be all right she'll be all
right you know i'm like no she won't and
then they had her on the gurney they
worked on her for 55 minutes in the
floor when they got there her heart was
beating 13 beats a minute and they
worked hard i heard them in there sandra
come on please you know they all knew us
where my grandma she fed the jail from
her restaurant for 30 years
so they all knew us very well that's why
she didn't want all the stuff out
because she's afraid it would ruin that
reputation
but um they got her on the gurney and
they were taking her through the living
room and i knew it was really bad
because they had the bag and there was a
emt straddling her on the gurney doing
cpr like this
and
like blood just pouring all over the
carpet as they took her out just falling
off the gurney
and um
they got her out to the ambulance and
they left i remember watching that and i
was like why aren't they using the
lights and sirens because they were
going slow i'm like they need to go
they're like they can't go no faster
because she's unstable you know they
don't know they got to get to the
helicopter the helicopter was waiting at
the other end of town they had already
landed and they had a
cardiothoracic surgeon on the helicopter
from the heart tower at mission hospital
so um they got her the helicopter the
surgeon said no and they pronounced her
dead there she never flew
so
um
we didn't have a lot of money then my
grandma lost her business after that
um
uh we lost our house
i went to college and i flunked out
i had a four-year scholarship flunked
out
see when i was growing up if i made
below an a i was beat mercilessly but if
i got an a i got 100 bucks see the two
extremes i'm talking about
you know they were great to me until i
[ __ ] up and then i was messed up
she would use a belt she would use her
hand she would humiliate me whatever she
needed to do you know
yeah and
i don't blame her because she was
psychotic
you know truly psychotic well now i've
been diagnosed i have bipolar one with
psychotic delusion but not schizophrenia
thank god
and um
i have severe ptsd
generalized anxiety i'm on like eight
meds
but i'm stable and i'm on suboxone i
haven't used in 16 months
um
i know i don't have any teeth i have
denture they hurt so bad they're cheap
ones so i don't wear them so after your
mom killed herself you started using
um yeah i started marijuana but no
that's the thing two days after she died
they took me to the doctor i was freak
you know i was basket case handed me a
script to xanax
immediately this is in the 90s 98 97
so 97 and um they didn't know then like
they do now you know and he told me he
handed me the script he said um when the
bad thoughts come take one and they'll
go away
by god they did
i overdosed two weeks later on
first first suicide attempt um i've been
to the hospital eight times
for suicidal ideation
stuff because just it gets the better of
me sometimes
you know the thoughts and worry and just
uh
everything you think you inherited some
of this from your mom oh definitely i
was already starting to be treated for
anxiety before she did this i think it's
from the abuse i really do because i was
just so nervous i'm still so nervous
i'm attracted to women now that beat me
the last girl i was with angie she beat
me so bad she broke my nose she blacked
my eyes
i mean
i just got out of that relationship it
was pure toxicity
and
i mean it's just that was my mom made
over she humiliated me constantly you
know drove me down told me i was
psychotic all the time and it was all my
head
cheated on me told me it was all in my
head
i mean you know it's really easy to pull
that card on me when i'm delusional
sometimes
but i'm stable now i'm on my meds i'm
doing good i'm 16 months sober
i mean i'm on ssi someone stay broke
obviously but other than that i mean i'm
happy now for the first time in my life
i found god
and
saved me
i don't have any nae i don't have any in
aaa i've got god that's all i need now
and
i have my dog and he's he's my other
world and i have a daughter who's 12.
yeah she lives with her mom in
burnsville and um i'm just getting back
in her life she's coming to my house for
the first time in years
to see me and
i've got a awesome place i'm in a
program that helps me get housing
um
after years and years of therapy i'm to
a point where i can get my driver's
license i just got to get me a car to
get my driver's license and
and
i'm happy for the first time ever in my
life and
i just want anybody to know like if
you're thinking about that or whatever
it really affects your family
in the long term long reaching
um painful
debilitating whatever words you want to
use it destroyed my life what she her
selfish decision that night suicide is
the most selfish decision a person could
possibly make
even when you think you're alone you
have god if you want to listen to him
and you want to let him in
you know he's always there you just
you let material things and drugs and
all this i did for so many years 22 20
years almost i was on drugs
tell me about that part of your life um
i started using xanax i overdosed like i
said on they gave me stronger ones
when i got out right i was my anxiety
was bad i was seeing therapists three
times a week
yeah i mean i still can't sit still you
probably see that but it's
um because i don't use any xanax or
benzos now i do it through other
medicines and
mine willpower
but um after that uh
people started bringing pain meds around
and i would trade my xanax's for the
pain meds because they gave me an even
better
it's all to numb everything mark you
know there's so much pain that i didn't
know what to do it just had to be numbed
some way somehow and wow opiates man
those are killer you know for that
because they take you to another plane
but then they stop taking you the other
plane and they start
you need them
and then
you have to have them and then oh my god
i'm be sick and you don't want to quit i
never used i used heroin once and i
thought i was going to die i never used
that again but i was on pain pills
really bad um oxies
you know war tabs whatever
and um
then
i learned
somebody traded me some cocaine for some
pain meds
and wow that was even better man cause i
could get up because i'm so i'm so
anxious anyway it felt good to get up
you know to be
to be up and i was like oh man this is
awesome it's awesome you got to try this
dude meth
you like being up i'll show you up man
and there it was that was the love of my
life all of a sudden you know
until 16 months ago
yeah i'd started shooting up
um
[Music]
you wouldn't recognize me 16 months ago
i was 105 pounds
i had a huge
cyst
abscess right here it was that big i
almost died if my um doctor and
therapist hadn't went and got my meds
and brought them to me and made me take
them
i was in meth induced psychosis um
the girl that beat me up whatever we had
just split and she left
one of my therapists was there one day
that's really all i have now my
therapist and stuff
and my dog and my daughter
and i walked to my bedroom door and i
was like she was on the bed with another
guy i'm like
dude help me get her out of here and he
walked over there he's like bradley
nobody's here man
i said then she jumped out the window
that was my logic he's like the window's
down man
there's a little hole that big in the
back of the closet i'm like they went
through that hole then
i'm like they were there he's like brad
go to the hospital with me and i was
like no i was no danger to myself you
know
finally i went to bed after that kind of
woke me up and i slowed down some
but i started shooting and then it got
bad again that's a whole different kind
of buzz when you start shooting it you
know and i was a i'm a shitty junkie so
i had absences all over myself because i
just can't hit
i would have to have her do it for me
but um
i just
and i got clean a couple times you know
been rehabbed none of that worked for me
because i wasn't ready
you know and then i used um
relationships
with women to try to um
team up to get sober together and i
learned that's a horrible mistake
you have to get sober for you not for a
relationship or for somebody else
and i learned that because i had an ex
that was staying with me
and i did everything i could for her to
stay sober with me and i realized the
draw
of something else is just too much
and
it was killing me
you know and i'm like man i'm not going
to risk everything anymore i got to
start thinking about me
and
it's really about self-love isn't it
yeah man i've learned to love myself i
love being single i don't i don't get
with women i have no sex drive
it something about the disorders has
messed it up that's part of the reason i
can't have relationships because i'm not
affectionate growing up i never touched
my grandmother or my mom we didn't hug
we didn't kiss we didn't well you know
but what i mean we weren't an
affectionate family and i never learned
that to me
i don't like to be touched
really by a woman or whatever you know
i'm completely heterosexual it's just
and i love to look at women and enjoy
women it's just i'm not an affectionate
person every once in a while i want sex
but like
on the daily i don't want to be
lovey-dovey and be bothered i just want
to chill with my dog and play games
and stream on twitch
was your mom ever affectionate with you
no no no no pretend she would act like
she wanted to be and then brutalize me
when i got close to her
like the the big one was come sit on my
lap on talk to you
you know you're a piece of [ __ ] and
throw me across the room
literally flew across the room
land in a heap
and i'd get up and next time she'd say
it i'd go back for more i guess i didn't
know better you know it's my mom you're
probably hoping it should be different
my grandma treated me like absolute gold
but we weren't affectionate we didn't
touch each other it was through money
that's how i am when i'm in a
relationship i want to get the person
everything but i don't want to be
affectionate with them
you've described how it's how having a
mom like that impacted your
relationships how do you think it's
affected your other parts of your life
like career and things like that there
is no career i'm on ssi i can't work
and i feel like all that
i don't want it to define me or i don't
want to play the blame game i've made
plenty of mistakes on my own you know i
won't blame her for half of what it is
but half of it
oh yeah she's she brings on the
affection thing
which affects other parts of my life
because i i'm very very sensitive and
i'll cry at anything and i'm like
they say i'm like a woman emotionally
i'm on steroids i'm actually on
testosterone
so it's like i'm starting to get that
edge back but they don't understand my
mom effeminated me constantly and i
never had a male role model except the
men that beat her my mom was beat
mercilessly herself
i saw her
my stepdad she married one of them dope
figure
um and she used to he said look at this
downstairs the furnace is leaking and
she went to look and went pow and kicked
her down the steps
why you know why
and broke her tailbone that time she
went doo doo doo doo doo
yeah
my stepdad tell me about your mom's uh
parents
my grandma i never met my grandpa
i met my great-grandma my great-grandpa
they died my great-grandma was awesome
she lived the life like 17 she was cool
but she was real old 90s
my grandma she never talked about her
husband she never talked about my
grandfather my mom never talked about
him
she said she'd never met him
so i don't know i just know his name was
samuel and he was from washington dc
that's all i know
so and i know my dad's name but that's
all i know i know he sent child support
that was his thing my mom said he was
married and she she had an affair he had
two other kids he came to town to do a
job and she was the town affair and he
knocked her up
and she said he came to the hospital
and said and she said that's your son
and his wife was with him and said take
a good look you'll never see him again
and that was the truth
so
so i never met the half brothers or
whatever that was never an issue i tried
to call him once and he answered the
phone
said we should meet up and have dinner
but
never met him he never followed through
so
and i have i'm always so afraid of
losing everything i worry constantly my
dog's gonna die my daughter's gonna get
sick
i'm waiting on the other shoe to drop
you know what i'm saying
what i mean by that and um
it terrorizes my life because
everybody's left and i'm so afraid of
the little bit that i have going away
you know when i came to this place i'm
at now everybody robbed me of what i had
i had a trash bag with some clothes and
a pair of jogging pants when i got there
you know and i've
i don't use drugs anymore so the little
bit of money i get goes to cool stuff
like my dog and stuff around the house
not much i don't really i don't do
i'm not extravagant at all but i'm happy
with my little simple stuff
you know they say material possessions
don't make you which they really don't
but man when you've had nothing
really nothing then it's really cool to
have stuff and say hey i got this man
i'm proud of it because it's mine you
know
maybe
i didn't
i earned it by being crazy or whatever
you know i used i use good honest money
to get it that's how i am now i've done
a lot of things in the past that weren't
right and i made a lot more money from
that
but like
it's just what kind of things are you
doing
it's drugs
i'm proud to make money yeah yeah
selling drugs yeah i have and just other
ways just fraud whatever i'm more the
white caller type
selling drugs is dangerous gets you
killed but um i was more a user in the
cellar it's more other ways i i just
think other ways
but um because i've been on my own you
know
so people don't get that i mean since my
mom died since seven years ago my
grandma died it's just me
you know everybody else thinks it's so
easy that they have this family to fall
back on they cannot grasp how it feels
to have
if you if i go to the hospital or i died
tomorrow i don't even know what would
happen to my dog you know what i mean
that really bothers me
bad stuff like that
you know every at my age even you're
still supposed to have a mom
and a dad or at least one you know
at this point
barring any tragedy you're supposed to
have family
my family never supported me when they
found out i used drugs that was it i was
done
i don't exist i've tried to reach out
now
no answer they ignore me
my one aunt she got in a bunch of
trouble but she stole my daughter's
identity to get taxes but i don't have
anything to do with her either so she's
a felon i'm not a felon i've not been in
much while trouble i've really not i've
got a marijuana charge that's about it
and um
so
i'm just
i'm loving life mark now finally for the
first time ever and
i feel like if i could get through to
anybody and tell them suicide's selfish
and don't do drugs
because i was over 200 pounds at one
time before i started using meth and
i've never been able to get my weight
back up again so it's i mean i've been
working out and i got better shape but
i don't know i don't treat my body as a
temple by any means but
i also realize that i want to be around
for my dog and my daughter
people like he loves it i love my dog
man he's my all day every day he's my
only friend it's just us you know my
other and my cat
but you know and
i never thought
i've made or surpassed every goal i've
had you know they didn't think i would
do well at all living on my own
you know and
i'm killing it
one of my old this
made my day one of my old therapists the
other
month or two ago
another friend of mine needed a place to
crash i'm that person hey call bradley
he'll hook you up i mean i'm all heart
but
don't get you very far in life usually
but i'm my heart
and um i said yeah you can crash here
tonight just so having my old substance
abuse counselor brought the chick there
to drop her off i'm like hey i'm like
see me now man that that's the same one
that saw me in psychosis that i didn't
that he thought that that i thought
something's there that wasn't i was like
look at this place i got man i said this
is mine now
he's like wow he cried mark
it got me man i'm so glad things are
better for you now things are a lot
better i mean
i don't have a lot of money but i'm
happy
i don't have any family but i mean i
make the most of what i have my ex-wife
is great she's a wonderful mother to my
daughter and we get along great and
co-parent i mean she's got her own
family but we're like best friends
so it's cool
really cool actually my daughter comes
anytime she wants to she's there last
weekend actually and wow
that's something that that my counselors
never imagined would happen
you know i was so far from that shooting
dope man
they're like wow man i'm like god
god it's not hard
fred what do you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
value your family
um
respect the life that god's gave you
and realize how beautiful the world
really is
and love yourself don't let anybody
downgrade you
and
find your own
find yourself
and once you find that everything else
will start falling in place so many
people don't do that so many people
don't appreciate their own self man
you're awesome in your own ways figure
it out do a self inventory figure that
[ __ ] out it's not that hard
all right brad thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem man i'm
glad things are good for you thank you
mark thanks
you